he's always interesting he's always
interested he's very smart
very private he's self-assured but shy
and I adored working with him Robert
Redford's work as an actor director and
producer always represents the man
himself the intellectual the artist the
cowboy he has a passion for telling
stories that reflect the strengths and
the vulnerabilities of the American
spirit our struggle to achieve what is
highest in our nature and though we
don't always succeed Robert Redford's
films make certain that we celebrate the
effort Redford took charge of his own
career from the very beginning always
working closely with writers his work as
an actor and as a director is always
skillfully subtle restrained and yet
deeply emotional he's a listener whether
he's exploring the shadow of American
politics the hidden emotional life of
the perfect American family or a
nation's disillusionment always a
progressive thinker and wanting to give
something back in 1981 he established
the Sundance Institute which has become
a platform for new artists to develop
their skills and has given the world
the festival has given the world a first
look at new generations of bold and
talented independent voices his impact
on the film industry is indelible it's
impossible to reduce it all to four
minutes but here are some of the reasons
that Robert Redford remains a beloved
and invaluable force in American film
I'm very very proud to bestow the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences honorary Oscar for lifetime
achievement to a man who gave me one of
the most exciting and memorable
experiences of my career I was thrilled
to be his leading lady and I'm thrilled
to present this award to Robert Redford
thank you I guess this is a sequel how
about barbers right I am I am shy it's a
funny kind of business to be shy in but
certainly feel that way tonight but I
think there certainly is a word of
appreciation in order for being honored
in such a way you know much of what
happens here tonight is probably going
to be forgotten in a week or so what's
not going to be forgotten is what it
means to those of us who are receiving
awards or being honored tonight and to
those close to us for those people it
could be the moment of a lifetime so in
my appreciation I'd like to say what it
means for me I've spent most of my life
just focused on the road ahead I've not
looking back
but now tonight I'm seeing in the
rearview mirror that there's something
I've not thought about much called
history and what moves me tonight is
that I'm being joined by colleagues and
peers to reflect on that history there
really are only two areas one is my
personal work which is the most
important to me and the other is trying
to put something back into an industry
that's been good to me and of course
Sundance is a manifestation of that the
result well a grande grande
collaboration of artists and colleagues
who have joined to support and help give
a voice to new artists those people who
have supported us along the way who have
believed and participated tonight
I would really like to thank you deeply
we have a great industry and we all know
that we're here because we know it we
love it it's a solid and healthy
industry but even though it is I really
believe it's going to be important in
the years to come to make sure that we
embrace the risks as well as the sure
things to make sure the freedom of
artistic expression is nurtured and kept
alive
because I believe that in keeping
diversity alive it will help keep our
industry alive
as we can see of late the world around
is in a sea change it's just simply not
the same world anymore as we all
struggle to find our way with it to get
a grip to make sense out of the chaos
and the destruction and the tragedy one
word that emerges is the word freedom
its importance its rarity and how
fortunate we are to have it to be able
to be part of a freedom of expression
that allows us as artists to tell our
stories in our own way about the human
condition the complexities of life the
world around us is a gift and not one to
be taken lightly then I think the glory
of art is that it can not only survive
change we can lead it as an artist I
just can't think of a better life and
the one that I've been blessed with it's
just a great ride with many wonderful
relationships and experiences along the
way and it's a ride I hope to continue
so tonight I want to acknowledge my
family my love for them my lady the
Academy and all of you for giving me
this honor thank